hablemos de replicación viral ya sabemos
que los virus están hechos solo de
proteínas y un tipo de acteón nucleico
lo que significa que no tienen organelos
para hacer copias de sí mismos por lo
tanto tienen que internalizar se en
otras células y usar su app y sus
órganos para hacer copias de sí mismos
así que el primer paso es entrar a la
célula vamos a mencionar varias cosas
como repaso y recordemos hay tres formas
de entrar a una célula una de las formas
de internalizar pse es la de los
bacteriófagos que literalmente inyectan
su material genético dentro de la célula
mientras que cualquier otro tipo de
virus usan uno de dos caminos si son
virus sin cubierta engañan a los
receptores de la célula para poder
entrar mientras que si tienen cubierta
pueden engañar a los
o fusionarse directamente con la
membrana una vez que el material
genético está dentro de la célula el
virus se apodera de ella y está listo
para hacerse cargo pero aquí es donde
tiene opciones puede ser impaciente y
estar listo para empezar a hacer copias
de sí mismo o relajarse y decir sabes
que voy a sentarme y esperar hasta que
esté listo para tomar el control
así que dibujemos estas dos
posibilidades por separado en la primera
posibilidad el virus impaciente toma el
control de la maquinaria de la célula es
decir su atp sus ribosomas sus ácidos
nucleicos sus aminoácidos todo esto para
empezar a hacer copias del material
genético del virus ya sea adn o arn
y también para fabricar las proteínas
virales para hacer su capa proteica y
éstas se auto ensamblarán lo que
significa que se unen por sí solas para
formar virus completamente funcionales y
debido a que se siga siendo más y más de
estos finalmente obliga a la célula
alisarse a romperse y una vez que se
rompe todos estos virus son liberados y
si hay otras células cercanas entonces
este ejército puede empezar a infectar
las es decir a apoderarse de estas
células cercanas y crear más ejércitos
así que esto tiene mucho sentido si
tienes muchos hospederos a tu alrededor
y tu objetivo es crear el ejército más
grande que puedas en el menor tiempo
posible este es el caso del virus
impaciente y ahora que hay de la otra
opción la otra opción es cuando el virus
decide colarse en una célula y
dentro de ella piensa no sé que a la
bacteria le está yendo bien sola tal vez
no hay otros hospedero cerca y por lo
tanto no hay razón alguna para matar al
hospedero ya que alisarlo lo mataría así
que no quiere esto y quiere mantener a
los poderosos y entonces para colarse y
dejar que la bacteria haga sus cosas
mientras espera va a combinar su
información genética con la del
hospedero el hospedero no debe darse
cuenta de que el virus anda por ahí está
básicamente tranquilo por aquí ya que el
virus está inhibido existen genes
represores en este virus por lo que no
hay expresión ni transcripción es decir
no está haciendo nada ya esto se le
llama pro virus o tal vez has escuchado
la palabra propagó una vez más como no
está haciendo nada podemos llamar a esta
una fase latente
la bacteria hace lo suyo se continúa
replicando y por supuesto el virus está
allí entonces el virus se replicará
también el virus se replica cuando lo
hace la bacteria porque ahora es parte
del genoma pero cerca de una de 10.000
veces que esto pasa o sea algo sucede
como que la bacteria se exponga a la luz
ultravioleta en cualquier caso existe
algo que debilita a alguien represor en
el virus el gen del que hablamos hace
rato y por lo tanto no seguirá
silenciado el genoma del hospedero como
la mayoría de los genomas querrá
repararse lo que quiere decir que se
recortarán para intentar reparar su
genoma y se extirpará parte de su adn
que es la parte del virus ahora el virus
está activo está listo para hacer copias
de sí mismo para alisar la célula y
esparcir su ejército para infectar otras
células
entonces el nombre oficial para el
método en paciente es ciclo político
mientras que el método de esperar en la
célula se le llama ciclo liso génico así
que ahora tienes una muy buena idea de
qué son los ciclos lítico y liso génico
en la replicación viral